eigentlich wollte die Regierung ja die
Bürger mit der Übernahme des Heizkosten
Abschlags im Dezember entlassen aber
jetzt müssen wir sagen eigentlich denn
nun steht fest das wird nichts Millionen
Bürger werden bis Frühjahr oder sogar
Sommer auf Entlastungen warten müssen
Grund die Zeit ist einfach viel zu knapp
ja konkret geht es in den gasabschlag
der ampelregierung hatte auf den
Expertenrat hin angekündigt ihn im
Dezember zu übernehmen um die
Verbraucher zu entlasten gestern liegt
eine Experten ihr Gutachten dazu vor und
dann heißt es unter anderem man könne
mit der Entlastung erst in der
Betriebskostenabrechnung die im Jahr
2023 für das Jahr 2022 vorgenommen wird
rechnen also heißt nichts mit Hilfe noch
in diesem Jahr tja ab März ist dann
außerdem noch geplant dass die
gaspreisbremse greifen soll damit soll
der Gaspreis dann für ein Jahr gedeckelt
werden Kanzler Scholz der erklärte die
Regierung werde bis Ende der Woche die
Details dazu vorlegen
dennoch ist klar jetzt ist November der
Oktober ist damit Geschichte und der
November der bringt allein neues was
ändert sich für Sie konkret wir helfen
Ihnen jetzt da müssen in den Überblick
zu behalten
neuer Monat viele Veränderungen ich weiß
was ab heute anders ist und wo sie so
richtig sparen können
Steuern und Versicherung ab heute müssen
Energieunternehmen ihren Neukunden
dieselben Preise anbieten wie den
Bestandskunden zumindest in der
Grundversorgung bei Steuern und
Versicherung heißt es Fristen beachten
allerletzte Chance für die
Einkommensteuererklärung 2021 eigentlich
änderte die Frist am 31 Oktober in
Bundesländern in denen der
Reformationstag aber ein Feiertag ist
endet die Frist erst heute die
Spritpreise gehen durch die Decke Auto
fahren wird immer teurer doch sparen
lässt sich auch bei der Kfz-Versicherung
mit einem Wechsel oft mehrere hundert
Euro im Jahr aber Achtung Stichtag bei
den Verträgen ist meist der 30 November
wechseln lohnt sich
und auch bei Netflix lässt sich bares
Geld sparen ab dem 3 November bietet der
Streaming-Dienst ein neues basis-abo an
Kosten nur 4,99€ pro Monat allerdings
das neue billig-abo ist nur mit Werbung
zu haben heißt Netflix schaltet vor und
während der Filme und Serien Werbeclips
beim Online-Bezahldienst PayPal gibt es
eine wichtige Änderung bislang hat der
Bezahldienst Rücksendekosten bei
Online-Bestellungen seiner Kunden
übernommen damit ist bald Schluss am 27
November endet der Service Retouren
müssen dann von Kunden selbst bezahlt
werden
für tierbesetzer könnte es schon bald
ziemlich teuer werden Ende November
dürfen Tierärzte mehr Geld verlangen die
Mindestgebühr für eine Untersuchung von
Hund und Katze steigt auf
23,62 Euro die Kosten für Impfung werden
sich sogar fast verdoppeln aber Achtung
Tierärzte können je nach Situation oder
Praxis auch den zwei bis vierfachen Satz
abrechnen
zum Schluss aber noch gute Nachrichten
Sparfüchse kommen im November voll auf
ihre Kosten am 11.11 ist single-day der
Einzel- und Online-Handel lockt mit
satten Rabatten und dann Ende November
gibt es ja auch noch den Preiskampf des
Jahres mit dem Black Friday am 25.11 und
dem Cyber Monday am 28.11 liefern sich
sämtliche Händler die ultimative
Rabattschlacht also zuschlagen
[Musik]
Steuern Versicherung und Rabatte er
november wird nicht langweilig und dank
Bild können Sie jetzt bestens
vorbereitet starten
ganz genau wir bereiten Sie noch weiter
vor und begrüßen dazu jetzt hermann
Josef tenhagener Chefredakteur des
geldratgebers finanztipp schönen guten
Tag guten Tag guten Tag viele
Verbraucher sind jetzt wegen der
steigenden Gaspreise in die
Grundversorgung gewechselt haben jetzt
aber teilweise höhere Tarife worauf
sollte man da ganz genau achten also
grundsätzlich gilt die Grundversorgung
ist tatsächlich der preiswerteste Tarif
wenn man jetzt eine Erhöhung bekommt die
Grundversorgung kostet ja zum Beispiel
auch gerade noch mal nachgeguckt in
Berlin 10 Cent bei der Gasag das ist
weniger als die 12 Cent die die
Regierung vorgesehen hat wo man später
Hilfen bekommen soll also Gaza Kunden
würden beim aktuellen Stand keine Hilfen
bekommen obwohl sich ihre Gasrechnung
verdoppelt hat aber in Cottbus zum
Beispiel ist der Gaspreis gerade bei 30
Cent und da wäre natürlich 12 Cent die
man dann künftig nur noch abrechnen kann
von der Regierungsseite her werden gut
also von daher immer gucken wenn man
eine Erhöhung bekommt vergleichen kann
man bei finanztipp auch machen und im
Zweifel beim Grundversorger noch mal
weil die Grundversorger tatsächlich oft
das preiswerteste Angebot haben viele
gucken jetzt im November natürlich auch
auf die Kfz-Versicherung die kann man ja
jetzt tatsächlich noch mal ändern was
gibt es da zu beachten es gibt zwei
Dinge zu beachten zum einen kann man für
das laufende Jahr bei der
Kfz-Versicherung noch Geld sparen wenn
Sie nämlich deutlich weniger Kilometer
gefahren haben als sie im letzten als
Sie angegeben haben bei der Versicherung
können Sie das jetzt der Versicherung
melden kleines Foto vom Tachostand
machen und dann einfach sagen ich fahre
dieses Jahr eben nicht 15.000 Kilometer
wie ich mal angegeben habe sondern nur
10.000 das gibt dann 15% zurück bei
praktisch allen versichern dass der
erste Teil und der zweite Teil ist
tatsächlich wenn ich jetzt die Rechnung
bekommen habe zu vergleichen Sie
bekommen nämlich im November
normalerweise die Rechnung dann können
sie hingehen und vergleichen mit
Vergleichsportalen oder bei finanztipp
nachschauen was ein günstiger
Versicherer ist und da ist
möglicherweise noch mal ein Hunderter
oder 150 Euro oder wenn sie recht viel
bezahlen auch noch mehr drin ganz
wichtig bitte nicht
monatlich diese Kfz-Versicherung
bezahlen viele Leute bezahlen die
monatlich das ist deutlich teurer und
wenn man die womöglich dann noch per
Rechnung bezahlt und nicht etwa als
Lastschrift wird es noch mal teurer das
kostet 10 bis 20 Prozent mehr sollte man
sich sparen weil das ja für eine
Versicherung dann schnell 100 150 und
auch 200 Euro sind immer mehr bezahlt
wirklich wertvolle Tipps sie im
Geldbeutel in echten Unterschied machen
die Steuererklärung ist ja auch noch so
ein Thema dass dann ansteht was mache
ich denn wenn ich da die Frist verpasse
wenn Sie jetzt die Frist verpasst
verpassen also sie müssten heute in
allen Ländern sozusagen in den
katholischen Ländern ist haben sie die
Frist schon verpasst in den
evangelischen wo der Reformationstag
Feiertag war können Sie heute noch sich
beim Finanzamt melden und sagen tut mir
leid ich habe die Frist verpasst weil
ich war vier Wochen krank wegen Corona
oder irgendein vernünftigen Grund und
dann sagen sie ich mache das in den
nächsten vier Wochen dann bekommt ihr
diese Steuererklärung ganz wichtig vor
den bei dem Hintergrund ist auch bei der
Steuererklärung die meisten Leute
kriegen Geld raus und 85 bis 90 Prozent
der Leute darum Geld zurück oft im
Schnitten Tausender das heißt wenn sie
sowieso jetzt gerade klamm sind dann ist
die Steuererklärung möglicherweise in
der oder vielleicht eine gute
Möglichkeit gilt zu bekommen und zu
verdienen und wenn sie keine Erklärung
machen müssen noch mal besonders der
Staat sagt nämlich nur sie müssen keine
Erklärung machen wenn er schon sicher
ist dass er alle Steuern von Ihnen
bekommen hat alle Leute die nicht
erklären müssen sollten das
Steuererklärung machen das kann man für
mehrere Jahre rückwärts machen und wenn
da jedes Jahr ein paar hundert Euro bei
rauskommt dann ist das das
Weihnachtsgeld von dem Sie immer
geträumt haben das sind wirklich sehr
gute praktische Tipps hermann Josef
Tenhagen danke ihnen sehr dafür vielen
herzlichen Dank
[Musik]